hi I'm westie and this is battlefield
Academy as you might have seen in the
first training video i set the squad
here the task of playing a match against
the public with minimal guidance from me
no tips no info drop them straight in at
the deep end this footage here is
highlights from that game behind you god
I'm like what I'm down please something
killed a girl yeah good eye for some
reason he's there to help I needed shoot
someone in the sniper over here okay
with you see what I've got a book oh my
god no my toes are stopped why did you
stop oh no oh my god it's cool grey
badly there's a tank for this isn't a
bit we have taken objective that yeah
okay um it's Hank then it's hangers
gonna soak scalp hey
oh yes get off who is it though getting
one get us go get old boy i got a
airplane everyone will try and keep it
four wheels on the great going to piracy
hi guys Oh what I die it's gonna be no
idea how I died I didn't go so well he
was driving they're taking F now oh my
god everyone actually hit anyone we've
got eating this is all bull all right
Wesley where do you need us well looking
at the map for him I hoped you hit the
guy on the plane I just did 72 damage to
him nice wasn't a headshot which is a
bit of a bummer yeah I got oh and the
bomber but we need to take our care
because they keep taking it
he stalled the bomber in the sky
here we go let's get it I think I can
hold still you know where the gouache
dad [ __ ] oh shoot i think my guns
broken its suit thing I the horse she's
going for him Shh winded oh really Oh
waiter coming up he's coming up how we
gonna sell if I come back I took why I'm
playing around on thurs all right just
not getting killed some of our teams
23mm he's down right we're winning is
keeping this job wait what not a peasant
shop for him I'm gonna go support
anyways thank you it's never guy coming
for the door I got a cutie they're all
the be right now all of it oh that's
taken out by the light whoa hey we have
taken objective apples run Randy silly
man man that's why ah the tank followed
me I peep around the corner to see the
night is holding me I'll crashed right
through the wall stretton ran me over
the energy deployed an arm would fight
oh no did they get the train yeah no I
guess so you can throw those at the
train all right I'm going suicide
mission
okay huge change Oh time I touch a huge
drain I got it I hit it nice then kill
it he was a hit yeah James you I'll say
that is single train guys they've taken
d yeah put dynamite on the train track
retreat ray okay okay i'll put it going
to scout in the lying down in the sand
over here on d way beyond being we're
bouncing two of them a spot one spot
over by the o the hiney go guy to keep
throwing grenades do you know just keep
throwing them I'm throwing them I'm
ready with a dynamite are there any on
foot I'm good jump it no don't come by
no no don't shut up Charlie coach Jimmy
yeah we need to take down the track it's
only got about ten percent health left
guys leave the train to me oh that's a
big Stan vs. Trane know i'd like to see
what happens here it goes i'll be okay
oh it's gonna tell you again go ahead
throw paint the shop but it's so hidden
time Oh better yeah my dads having me
that was nice we know if I'm ever day
glad you mop yeah cute some smash cute a
great question how do you want oh thank
you to our trigger nice boys get one
good one my god I can't shoot someone
it's all running on any now if anyone's
got the ammo pouches
try to be done to reach a lot on the
right you sure on the side I see in this
movie as a yes i'm with the simon tips
now spot it through right oh my god how
many i'm here with minute it's so many
at we're just I know saving eyesore and
I need one more kill for my order of the
staff Oh Freddie Oh that bother waiting
over there by the tank on our team he's
on this letting under the region he's
hiding I got home he got me I ladies
bear me come one off my overdragon I
can't see this guy who's right here I
got it what number you guys a bell it's
jeffy oh hell no okay yeah waiting for
me there's two three guys know my medal
and what my matter we reach someone oh
no you ah yeah run run run my silly now
my lord what is going on I don't know
right guys ask mo two guys over here on
the on the left hand side by then one
shot one shot don't larger gotta hit
marker on another thick as mentor this
air battle he hosted tears
that's why I've got steady oh the
anti-tank grenades no still in the lead
with 40 points off winning we saw it
before we just normal again we just need
to take the subjective yes are okay
today yeah the Pacific salmon our team
is 58 and wider hope his last ridiculous
he was coming in in the wine I need to
see him oh yeah something in playing
you're gonna oh yeah Donna well I scale
kills me I'll ever again I hit an enemy
with a plane but 59 and one you've got
being attacked surely is this probably
sign of tanker fire round to one end of
rounds near
there I'm gonna buy a nice go ah we need
20 points guys we need to turn that but
I was in the guy threeway know your
linux kill his head he just got up and I
enjoyed member to see guy yeah we're
going we go now yeah guys are all over
it with seven points away from winning
we got this we got d 1 i'm sorry thanks
penguin is that so yeah throw the
grenades throw all the grenades unique
clover foreign aid yeah it's a valid
tactic do it sorry yes sir great it huh
we push them with more ticket yeah okay
what remain a party without it nearly
there guys anymore babe me West be any
second whoo wait you all getting with
the melee the parade ah yes a guy hiding
it let's get a point for victory guys
were behind on points but cute yes that
went surprisingly well good job we don't
need any training at all we've got this
already considering this was their first
match of battlefield one I was very
surprised actually that they picked up
the basics so quickly then he latched
onto the Scout role really well Brad and
spam fish gravitated into support roles
and kept the team topped up with
bandages for their wounds and ammo for
our guns and cam pulled off some heroic
acts to bring down the armored train
risking his own life for the entire
squad like I said the basics are there
but they clearly still rough around the
edges and we need to shape them into a
proper squat make sure you stay tuned
for the next training video where we'll
be dropping big knowledge and seeing how
they cope
play it first with EA access